i'm afraid about abortion is that it's
gonna always happen anyway it's one of
those things that they try and say like
now that it's illegal it'll stop but
like
it's been what do they say 9 90
the numbers of abortions are like
staggering when you look at them and
those are the ones only on record in the
united states that we know of so there
was an instance of a study that was
performed on back alley abortions which
i know is a big topic that people talk
about a lot the guy went to his deathbed
and he admitted that like half of the
numbers he just
made up just like that he just made it
up he just wanted abortion to happen he
wanted it to be legalized he literally
lied and i need to find the study
you guys are welcome to fact check me
but
based on what my understanding of the
back alley abortion thing women are more
likely to die
in an actual legalized setting even with
medical care they're more likely to have
negative response to it and super regret
after the fact than any kind of back
alley abortion yeah i don't agree with
the idea that they'll happen anyway you
know we hear that a lot from a lot of
the the the pro-abortion activists used
to be pro-choice people but i don't know
where they went because i still consider
myself pro-choice but uh the argument is
that it'll more of you know oh it'll
happen anyway i'm like i don't believe
that's true i believe in may you know
there was like that that viral instance
i think i don't know who it was they
held up a coat hanger you know we're
we're going back to that or whatever and
i'm like that's messed up i'm not a fan
of that at all but uh i think an
overwhelming majority of women would
just have babies but what would happen
would they get like criminalized the
ones that tried to get enough what
what this law says is that someone can
sue if they find out someone aided or
got an abortion and they can they can be
awarded like 10 grand i think it is yeah
10 but not the woman herself right oh
you can't you can't sue the woman you
can sue the doctor it is
it is really clever what they did so
apparently
it used to be that these laws always got
struck down because the state had no
right to intervene in medical procedures
and so the state is saying the law
actually borrows the state from
enforcing this it only allows for
lawsuits where
civil cases are brought by other
citizens so that's apparently how they
are planning to get around this but
again they're acting like it's the end
of roe v wade but like you said this was
this was dropped because of lack of
standing in which case it could be
another week or or you know when it goes
into effect i think was it like
september or you know it went into
effect yesterday okay right on the first
right so we get it for someone right now
just be like okay i'm suing and then the
supreme court would be like yeah you
can't do it and they will yeah and and
it will go on uh
you know the the law will be prevented
from from taking effect and they'll go
into lawsuit and i mean i don't think
it's gonna change anything in the courts
but it is a necessary step you know you
know my issue is with the whole thing
you know
i don't know where the line is that you
allow the government to say we can
mandate somebody provide their body to
somebody else i don't know where that
line is where the government is allowed
to intervene in that capacity and i'm
very scared about what that means when
we accept the government can intervene
in that capacity so let's just say
so here's the conundrum
a woman uh
you know ends up you know pregnant and
there's a health risk a very serious
health risk and she's devastated by this
she desperately wants to have children
and she's been she's struggling with it
and so they go to the doctor and the
doctor says the baby will not survive
and neither will you like our only
option right now is termination
and then what you got to file petition
to the state
or is that is that an exemption in the
texas law it's an exemption so the
doctor can incest rape health of the
mother are all exempted from this law
that's when you just said incest and
rape and when you said this law was very
cleverly crafted this law was very
cleverly i wouldn't i wouldn't say out
clever maybe the wrong word i think
maybe perhaps the answer to that is
fairly solid solid yeah so they don't
want this lot to get struck down by the
typical
ways that has been struck down in the
past it's not about striking down does
that mean to say that they're actually
creating a window for use for abortion
as use of con as contraception
if they're if there is a medical
exemption meaning you can get a
termination due to the health of the
mother incest or rape
well after six weeks
before six weeks anyone can have one
there's no restrictions for before six
that means only after the six week mark
that means this this the bill is
actually saying women are free to use
abortion as a form of contraception
absolutely wow as until until
uh six weeks and then is that six weeks
from conception
i was just reading about this because
sometimes it's not until two weeks after
your last period that you can actually
conceive so they'll think they're
pregnant for two weeks and then they
don't actually get pregnant and then all
sudden they're pregnant well it's the
heartbeat bill so it's not actually
about six weeks it's about if they can
detect a heartbeat then you can't get an
abortion
unless there's exceptions you know in
those in those regards it's it's so
here's the conundrum does the state then
say
sorry we don't care about the
circumstances or whatever it may be
outside of these exceptions we are going
to mandate your body is provided to this
other independent you know living oh
could you confirm two weeks conception
typically occurs about two weeks after
your last period begins all i know is
that in case any one of the viewers are
like why are you guys talking about this
our friend jack pasobic made it clear
since men can get pregnant now and then
they talk about it that's correct and i
was like that was that was one of the
most genius tweets i ever saw he was
like if men can get pregnant and we can
talk about abortion yes but now it's
it's are you a birthing person
but not talking about this law which was
what people were saying saki the
president they all talked about how this
is a threat to the rights of women so
the birthing person was not used today
so now we are back to women are the ones
getting pregnant which i think for the
trans community is incredibly
transphobic i just i just i just i this
is a giant i thought we played i talked
with glenn back and we had a really
really great conversation about it
because i was just like
i hear all your arguments i agree with a
lot of your um you know your your um i
agree with your starting point and where
your arguments are coming from
but then i think about the government
saying
at this point in time
that independent living creature that is
living off of your blood and using your
body
well we're going to make sure that that
stays that way and i'm like
man but this is my body i have one life
to live you know i don't want anybody to
to be like i'm going to provide that
body to somebody else by force
and i know a lot of people don't like
slippery slope arguments but could there
be a point where it's like there's a
there's like there's an accident the
government says well the you crashed
your car and the person you hit you both
have the same blood type so we're going
to mend it you give blood to keep them
alive like at what point are they then
going to get more and more invasive
because
entertaining the idea that the
government has a right to intervene that
you provide your body to someone else
for some moral reason well the person's
gonna die and we can't let a life die
especially when you have the opportunity
to provide something to save them so
we're gonna mandate you do
then we have start having arguments
about how much of your body is welcome
to be you know given to somebody else
now of course i know the argument the
response to this is simply that like
pregnancy is a unique circumstance
outside of injury so we could easily
carve that out and say pregnancy
especially arising from the individual
choices like because rape is exempted
this is a woman who made a choice got
pregnant and now is responsible for that
action i understand that i understand
that i'm just there's like a libertarian
wall and stands before me i'm like i
don't know how you get past that for me
morally i don't know well i think
libertarians as like even as a political
party their platform is pro-choice i
think most liberty except for the
philosophy
the oh okay i don't know yeah yep yeah
dave smith is pro-life how could you be
libertarian and be pro-life yeah because
their argument is that this the state
libertarians do believe in the state and
they believe that like one of the most
one of the paramount things of this of
the state's uh mission is to protect
life
kind of life though
so like uh
we have a government that is trying to
make sure people can live
you know and it's one of the goals of
government to prevent death so stop
someone from murdering somebody else and
that's why they're pro-life because they
view the baby with a heartbeat as its
own independent living entity it has its
own dna it has its own heartbeat it is
growing and developing
and at that point
removing it from the womb would
terminate it in which case
you know you can't do that but i do have
a question in the capacity then would
there be a law that says the women can
remove the baby at around five months
when the baby becomes viable outside of
the wound and then put into care and
then adopted
you know what i mean
because if the real issue is killing the
baby then once the baby comes to a point
where they know the the the fetus fetus
to be viable you know outside of the
womb could it then be removed
like not to kill it but to actually let
it grow and live and flourish very risky
option yeah it is i know i don't think
most people most parents that want to
have a preemie that's like you know but
think about the argument if the argument
is that you can't end the life i get it
then what if it doesn't end the life
yeah and you then sever it from you know
the womb
i i don't see that as a viable
alternative to the problem here but if
the baby can live isn't that i don't
think that's guaranteed at the
five-month mark it's not guaranteed so
then would there be a legal debate over
like well let's six months actually you
can you know they can do a c-section and
or or or
women into forced labor and then the
baby can be premature and then be
treated to grow and survive because it
works it doesn't kill the baby then
right um so is it abortion or is it
wouldn't be abortion induced premature
labor right or adoption yeah it would be
an early pregnancy induced pregnancy and
you know or induced uh labor yeah
the challenge i think that we're dealing
with is uh the reality of what it means
to be a living entity trying to ask
ourselves questions about individual
sovereignty bodily autonomy but also the
fact that we are biological entities
that use our bodies for reproduction
and then what does it mean that when a
woman gets pregnant
there are two individuals involved
that's how the law views it especially
in car accidents and murder cases if the
woman's pregnant there's two entities
and then how do you how do you determine
rights for people who are attached to
each other i'll i'll give you another
wild crazy scenario conjoined twins
and you know uh they're both legally
carrying firearms in the good old state
of west virginia but then one of the
conjoined twins and a fit of rage just
freaks out and shoots somebody in cold
blood wow do you then put the other twin
into prison
oh like serious i'm i'm i'm not i'm not
no that's that's a fascinating you got
it i'm just i'm gonna say no no i can't
but
i'm simply bringing this up to show the
the problem of trying to guarantee
liberties to an individual when they're
joined together so i don't have the
answer so basically we need a law that
says conjoined twins cannot possess
firearms ah yeah like that's how you get
away with it if you have someone on an
inc on an intubator and they're
unconscious they and you're like their
family member you have the right to pull
the plug on that machine i believe right
in most states if no not not this was
the was it the terry shot
yeah yeah there's there's states where
you can't do it no matter okay that's
similar to abortion because the baby
can't speak for itself it's essentially
unconscious in your inside of you and
you have full control of its breathing
and it's
so you you have to make the decision
whether it's going to get the plug
pulled or not then there's euthanasia
yeah and i'm just like man i do not have
the like
i don't know
i have friends flat out who say when i
hit 72 and if i start having we talked
about dementia before we went on yeah
they were like i am flying myself to
switzerland and i am they're like i am
not going to go through that myself i'm
not going to put my family through that
um
i i it's already daunting to have like a
40 year old friend say oh no that's the
plan um but but people yeah i would
encourage them to uh
research psilocybin before they do that
i hear that that's good for dement that
helps dementia clear the plaque off the
uh
the neurons
actually i think it's thc thc will eat
the plaque off the neurons in your brain
i don't know about that ian yeah there's
video there's video of it go on youtube
and watch thc eating
eating thc the one that actually gets
you stoned or is that the okay
i always get my acronyms confused all of
these things i think bring us to a very
very simple point
it's like that that i think with the
judge talking about porn he says you
know when you see it yeah cannabinoids
remove plaque from all sides there's
there's uh the way referred to it is
there's the the uh particle form and the
wave form of an argument
the particle form is where we can easily
quantify what is good and what is bad
and we say this goes in the bad section
this goes in the good section like thou
shalt not kill we know that's bad and
you know but well i guess then we gotta
carve out for like self-defense and we
gotta cover up for like you know warfare
and things where we find justifiable
death okay well well there's some things
that are clearly bad you know don't
attack people unprovoked for no reason
bad section then when it comes to how do
we
deal with the liberties of individuals
when there's more than one individual in
the circumstance that can't be removed
from it and we're like you know what
there is no easily quantifiable way to
define define this and that's what i
would just call describe more as the
wave form it it takes a massive gradient
of different opinions in different areas
and there's you know there's no middle
there really is no middle because if
you're if you're pro-choice and this is
something i recognize there's going to
be abuse of the system there's going to
be people who are like i'm just going to
use abortion as contraception and i'm
like well that's wrong right but i'm
worried about the government getting it
wrong i'm worried about someone being
like i have this problem i need an
exemption and the government going
nah
and you're like why do i have to ask you
it's my life i'm honestly not concerned
if some guy i don't know kills his own
baby that i don't know in india i just
don't care right now do you care really
yes that someone somewhere you've never
heard of is destroying an unborn baby
that you've never heard of somewhere
what does that even have to do with you
in the universe though because i'm not
selfish but it has nothing to do with
you it has a lot to do if you get
involved you're being selfish no
what does it have to do with you man see
i believe i believe life exists for the
purpose of creating complex systems out
of free energy and i believe that when
you look to what what we should do and
what is good good is creation protection
development progression and bad as
destruction and chaos
too much good is cancer no too much
creation is cancer
right so that's why there's there's
there's there's good with an evil
there's evil within that within good
there's yin yang there's destruction
good there's creation within evil so so
uh right uh cancer is is is is is
disorder it's like it's evil creation
but cancer is disorder right the human
body exists in a well as a well-ordered
machine that destroys cancerous cells
it's part of the process to to ensure
that it persists but when it when the
machine breaks and cancer develops it's
actually destroying the system and
preventing the growth and development of
new complex systems so when i hear
stories about people somewhere else
doing horrible things and destroying
things i'm like this goes against what i
view life is here to be doing they are
causing massive destruction that's
that's that's a negative to
the goals of of development creation
progress etc so i think it's bad and i
and and it's not just about me the world
isn't about me and my perception what i
want i don't just exist so that i can
have things i want the world to
genuinely improve and be better and i
hope that there's a future out there in
100 200 years of humans traveling the
stars and continuing the development of
organizing energy into complex systems
and then eventually they
ascend into a higher being of a greater
level of development and then eventually
human entity whatever it is evolves
develops creates robots something else
that then starts creating its own
universes as the next phase of the
creation of complex systems destroying
things breaking things for no reason
makes me mad but there is a reason that
that is to protect the woman for
abortion anyways the odd is the idea but
but but i agree with that right if
there's a woman who would die
or it would cause negative it would
cause destruction then we intervene
if it's a woman who's simply saying i'm
going to destroy i'm like that's bad the
problem is if the government gets it
wrong and they do all the time i don't
want the government involved and i
understand that it'll be abused which is
a very difficult moral position but i
air towards the libertarian side because
i'm scared of what government does with
too much power yeah right i used to have
pretty much your exact perspective on
that like what do i care if somebody has
an abortion and whatever reasons they
choose i had a pretty decent lefty
indoctrination at university um but that
changed when i uh when my son was born
going through that process of pregnancy
and birth and then taking care of
something that small and fragile totally
reversed my so i don't think that you
can necessarily have that change of
perspective unless you go through that
yourself because i mean that's at least
where i'm coming from i mean you had a
very elaborate explanation for your
perspective but for me it's very
personal um and going through that
myself it totally changed my perspective
of abortion i hope your wife is watching
right now because that's the cheers
that's the sweetest thing i have heard
yeah
you know
i want a baby that was that was great i
love that we had uh in the first place
in our first incubation of the baby of
the chicken eggs i had 12 eggs
at one point one of the eggs started to
rot
and i didn't know which one and i looked
online and i checked the data and i
asked some people and they said here's
what you could look for but they were
all identical when i candled them i took
the light put the eggs and i smelled
them
and there was more than one that was
probably rotten and then i was like damn
what do i do because they explode they
can burst because the bacteria grows and
then a minute and then it could infect
the other eggs so you've got to get it
out of the incubator and so i said i
candled as many as i could these look to
be fine and i'm gonna i'm gonna
hopefully i'm getting the right ones and
then when i took them out
one of them may have actually been a
viable baby
and i felt so bad
that this this life was growing and you
could see it and one of them was black
like it was it was like there were a
couple of them just black came out like
bacteria and gross and so i was like i
had to do that to preserve the
development the growth and the creation
and i knew the risk was going to be that
i could i could actually kill one of the
new baby chicks and i may have and it
was a miserable feeling and i feel
absolutely distraught over it and it was
just a chicken and now we have these
three little baby chicks that jump
around and playing and doing the little
chicken thing and we open the cage and
they jump out and they're jumping all
around and they're very nice and they
flap their little wings and they're
adorable and they're living and i want
to protect them
and so when i think about the issue of
you know life and you know all this
stuff i i absolutely feel that way about
other babies like i don't just hold
chickens to high esteem i'm like it is
it is a is a painful feeling man if you
i couldn't imagine what it must be to go
through that having to make these
decisions or whatever for a person who's
had to go to a clinic and deal with this
stuff
these these are hard moral questions man
i said i'm not a priest this has been
the most um um
unemotional
abortion conversation i've ever been
part of and that's and it makes me think
like how many more conversations could
we have as a society where we all have
very strong opinions and what is a more
controversial subject right than
abortion and and and and we disagree at
the table but boy oh boy was this such a
this is like an example of civility it
was very nice to be part of yeah i like
that it's the ben shapiro thing that
facts don't care about your feelings i
think that this is one of those
conversations that we need to be able to
have because i know that i disagree with
so many people and they're not going to
change my mind and i'm probably not
going to change theirs but you were
talking about cancer ian and you're also
talking about maybe like a little baby
in india you just don't really care what
happens to them and i think that if you
consider the fact this is a very cliche
but if you consider the fact that if
you're going to take a child out of the
equation you have no idea what their
potential is they could literally cure
cancer but it doesn't matter if they
could cure cancer or not because if they
could make one person's life better over
the course of their life whether they
have down syndrome or something or if
they just become a parent who makes a
positive difference in the world for
their own kids you're removing that from
the equation without ever giving them a
shot at life that's what i have an issue
with it's not really emotional it's like
you don't
eff around with the potential of human
life they could be hitler for sure yeah
obviously if they're born to a bad
situation it could be way worse than
that
there's there's there's good and there's
bad people and um
but i but you know i i thought about
something especially why i oppose the
death penalty
is because
i just i read about i read stories and i
read about people's experiences
and i was reading about death row
and it was like a guy who was going on
death row at the very last minute they
they they put a a a a halt or whatever
on the on the execution stay on the
execution and then later turned out the
guy was wrongly convicted and then i was
like i could only imagine
being told we are going to slowly walk
you to a painful death
knowing that soon what makes you you the
uniqueness of you would be snuffed out
and you were innocent and i was like
that is one of the most horrifying
things i i feel like a person could ever
experience
it's like a mock execution it's like you
have no power
you have done nothing to deserve this
and we are going to end you now
and this guy was you know there's a
bunch of stories like this but i was
like wow i could not ex i i i believe
killing is wrong i believe that human
beings are all
you know you know what's funny
we can talk about a bitcoin you know a
crypto and its unique hash code and how
there can be trillions upon trillions
all of these unique codes humans
are like
uh to to to the to the tenth power to
the hundredth power unique every little
bit about them from their ideas and
their developments to the words they use
the way they speak to the color of the
hair all become this extremely unique
you know what it's like to have to be
you know two two pieces of matter can't
occupy the same space it's almost like
the same time two formations cannot be
the same in this universe so that we
have we're forced to be unique by
becoming different than our surroundings
i just mean to say that uh you know to
quote dr manhattan or to paraphrase dr
manhattan that you know with all the
matter in the universe that could have
come together a woman loves a man she
had every reason to hate and all that
came was you a miracle something that
shouldn't exist brilliant comic and
brilliant movie and so i each each
individual person is my dad when i was
young i think we lost our cat or
something happened to a cat and i was
like oh it was really sad oh my the cat
he's so sad my dad was like
it's a cat
and i remember like he's based in like a
fireman like a legit blue collared dude
just like yeah that puts it in
perspective it was a cat like what are
we doing here on earth
it didn't it it wasn't like i say you're
saying all life is valuable but you're
talking about human life and you're
saying killing is wrong i was talking
about murdering bro i was talking about
a chicken that made me feel miserable
because i accidentally made it it's a
chicken that's that was beautiful it's a
hierarchy of life though sure
we respect all life like we shouldn't be
killing things but clearly like we do
hunt we eat meat absolutely so yeah so
just to make sure we're not egalitarian
in that sense like all life is the same
that's definitely not it's definitely
not and you were saying but there are
there are practical reasons not to eat
people you were so absolutely yeah
that's true disease diseases yeah yeah
but also it's just like although i
wouldn't taste good
killing was wrong and i imagine you
meant like killing humans was wrong when
you were talking about it but but like
is it no
murder is wrong because killing enemy
soldiers is right
according to our societies moral
standards probably not i wouldn't say
it's right but i would say it's
justified it's justified it's good for
our friends to say it's good oh it is
good in war if you kill the enemy and
you survive it is good well in the sense
that like it's better than he kill you
yes but i don't think it's not good i i
don't think
gosh that would be dangerous as a
society if we say like it is good that
we killed all those arrests
that was necessary justified killing is
wrong better he killed i killed him and
then he killed me but but i can't
so destruction uh for the purpose of
destruction
destruction for the purpose of
protecting life is different when we
kill a chicken to eat it it's because
it's part of the process of organizing
free energy into complex systems and in
order to survive so we eat we we kill
and eat but if someone went around with
with a with a a a 410 and just popping
off people's chickens they'd arrest them
and lock them up that's why i'm going
after those animals that are eating my
chickens yeah although he's although
he's doing it to eat exactly the mom was
doing it to feed her cubs she's just not
doing it for my chickens the fox is
justified so we have dogs
it makes me think like is it at what
point is it murder because i think
murder is inherently wrong that pretty
much everybody agrees in society our
society is wrong so are you murdering
the baby for is is it murder or is it
killing of a of a life form that's in
development like at what point is it
considered murder when you do it for no
reason
other than
you know what i didn't want this to
happen and whoops i'm not responsible so
i'll just you know
i guess i just feel like the choice to
abort is at best a poor executive
decision on behalf of the mother
i agreed you think it's better to give
up for adoption
it i don't know i don't know that's
that's really tough to say i
i guess there are some circumstances
where that would be the case but not
always
maybe not even the majority you know i i
i so want
like people not to get abortions but man
there's literally in my mind i keep just
hitting a libertarian wall of like i
don't understand why the government
intervenes and stops someone from making
a decision that i have no business being
involved in other than to protect
innocent life but then i don't know the
circumstances there's no way i could
know the circumstances that means
there's going to be a lot of abuse and
i'm like damn that sucks i have no idea
what to do yeah
but that is the role of government at
least have we have we have it ordered
right we do ask the government to step
in you mentioned terry shivo we asked
the government to step in in those
circumstances where the vulnerable do
not have the potent the ability to
protect themselves otherwise let's just
kill the homeless
right who who advocates for the whole
thing that's very different why why
what's what's what's wrong with them
they're they're they're strung out on
drugs they're uh they're
not coherent they're just contributing
they're not contributing to society they
pose a danger to so a lot of them so
let's just if we just get rid of them
what's
is that murder no it's just it's just
calling
right but no
of course the government steps in is
like someone has to protect these people
from those who would do them harm you do
a really good point what
when these international elites talk
about humans as if they're livestock
overpopulating
yeah they view it very in a very
utilitarian manner of like well for the
betterment of mankind you know we've got
to do something about x well what about
that yeah like your libertarian
sensibilities were saying you don't want
the government to get involved with that
well you know the china two par one
child policy the there are people here
in america who who talk about population
control
very comfortably and the rules that we
should have of just one child per family
you have to be a way to go with number
two on the way
you have to be a sociopath
to entertain the notion of culling human
beings because as humans we strive to
protect each other and to flourish and
to love and to live and we hold
ourselves to the highest hierarchical
standard in terms of life and hence the
genre of post-apocalyptic movies and
books from uh uh hunger games to the uh
the the maze maze runner and uh the the
the choo choo train in the snow they're
all that same idea but i wanna just
mention that i did ask alex jones this
question when we were when we were on
the show and i said what if they're
right what if we are expanding too
rapidly ignorant to our own impending
demise because we're like yeast in a
bottle eating the sugars and farting
ourselves to death what if there needs
to be some kind of intervention to make
sure humanity survives and alex said
it's a tough question i think about it
you know ask myself the question every
day and i just don't know thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you